it's the greatest street fighting
tournament instead of flying everyone
all over the world
we fly everyone one time one flight to a
central location I'm suggesting Atlanta
never oh yeah who likes the Falcons ha
ha ha ha we're literally buying like
eight plane tickets per fighter business
class yes it's totally worth it i
doesn't realizing where i got this voice
from it's from the voice from the game
the else's all his [ __ ] sorry um
yes one other thing I wanted to talk
about was uh one of the events you have
the contestants destroying a fully
loaded Mercedes s-class it's a test of
strength blocks of wood is also a test
of strain easy to make blocks of ice is
also testing strength wouldn't you agree
that that is all a test of two I'm
Stewie from Family Guy ha ha ha ha hey
brain come on
Elena's not that bad chin up do you know
how many times I've been to the
coca-cola museum you will be broke our
profits do not justify our losses that's
how business works
am I really that low on cash will your
divorce